good morning John that's the bookshelf
that used to have all the stuff on it
all through all the top shelves but down
here in the bottom is where apparently
I've been keeping all of my memory stuff
all of the nostalgia my high school
diploma journals for terrifying our
family tree that I created an elementary
school in Oh John you are not on this
not sure who I hate it feel like that
could probably go in the trash time
Frasier this is art by my friend Jeff
they're mock-ups for SimCity 2000 tiles
got to keep that not gonna read you any
other writing oh but this pickup hockey
not for the weak there's fine print at
the bottom of my flyer it says this is
not a school sponsored event so if you
die your parents can't sue the school
okay girls welcome tough on the top yeah
Mars art this is a city that lived on
the rim of a crater well into the
terraforming of Mars yeah here's an
alien that has 18 pack abs one two three
four five six seven eight nine ten
twenty pack 20 pack abs lava lamp
creature some kind this is a merman two
sets of arms God that had give him two
sets effects there so that he would be
more anatomically correct also the whole
18 pack is going on there I was into ABS
apparently oh here's just excellent
death is electrocuting some guys in a
cave and there's a dragon falling into
the Sun it's a mouth eating another
mouth oh yeah
why not well that's a little terrifying
more too many abs this person's hand is
a plant crater City oh yeah you just we
domed that whole thing up it's actually
on the back of some homework David be
Giants fan art oh well excellent
uh this is ASCII art of the different
manners in Magic the Gathering had had
to print that out oh my god I see these
in my dream sometimes and then I'm like
I don't know how to get to that class
then I'm 34 years old can I stop having
that dream oh hello there September 2nd
1997 congratulations you have been
selected to be one of the Willie Wildcat
personalities I was a mascot in my high
school this entire binder is just notes
from my friend some of these things are
just beautiful like I want to frame this
this is what we did before there was
tumblr you guys where you can text
everybody all the times a lost art all
I'm saying yes
send notes if you're in high school or
did you when you were in high school I
would like to know this is every year of
my life it's a personal timeline what I
want to do every year of my life what
year is it now it's it's 2014 find five
new tropical fish I assumed that meant
to discover the species of tropical fish
I did not achieve that though I do have
a fish tank and so I find them at the
fish store 2018 find the Loch Ness
monster so I've got some years to find
the Loch Ness monster John Green my big
brother age 14 loves football and
beating up little kids is what it says
about my brother John oh my god is that
my magic cards oh my god it is it's my
magic card what the heck this is a check
from John for $200 what the heck
I didn't deposit this check John's
signature was totally different uh-huh
there's so much cool Brotherhood 2.0 art
stuff oh wow I don't know where I got
this but it was clearly a handmade like
plastic resin cassette tape holder and
inside of it I have a dollar bill that I
have cut all of the darker parts out of
why here's me explaining to my mom how
to use a pipette whoa I didn't know I
had so many pictures of me as a little
kid you mean John sleeping together and
again I'm gonna save these for some
future throwback Thursdays so you better
be following me on Instagram this big
white wall behind me is making me sad
it's a place that a lot of amazing
things have happened to me in I don't
the game of image that we're moving to
different apps but we are we will be in
the new house next week and I'm looking
forward to sharing it with you and
filling that place with as many awesome
memories as we have had here
John I'll see you on Tuesday